[Music]
the game of the hour the release date or
the release embargoes went up this
morning review emergency view embargo
what did I say Luther learned America
it's the same thing
nope no its review embargoes went up
this morning our very own Lucy James
over in the UK reviewed persona 5 yeah
last week we talked about could this be
your first in the series I'm back to
answer that question yeah ikaw this is
my first game the series I'm really
liking it I played it til 4:00 a.m. he
came in the office he's like I love
persona it's so cool I like ripped my
clothes off and started chanting no I'm
just kidding
I want to ask you guys what your persona
would be bogan to that of course anyway
this game released in Japan how long ago
I want to say last December no no
everyone went to TGS and came back with
copies yeah yeah and everything that
they were saying based on that version
was phenomenal I can't read Japanese I
think I'm not really I don't know um but
yeah this game is fun I mean I like it a
lot we like I said last week on the
lobby I don't know the series I really
liked I mean what's the prize here about
it uh it actually at first I was kind of
like I don't get why people like this I
mean it was fun I do like I have a few
things on to talk about actually its
subverting a lot of my expectations of I
know sometimes you think is a
problematic term JRPG only the
problematic time I think it's a dumb
term okay well the intense this
conversation I like like eastern RPGs
that style oh my god that's worse
I like JRPGs I enjoy you know like
turn-based kind of grind heavy RPGs I
don't play them as much as I would like
to because you know like nature of our
job we have to play a lot of games but
they're very time consuming exactly and
I actually think this game makes that
grind interesting and fun so for those
who don't know there are like kind of
two sides to persona games I mean Cal
you played a lot as you wanna well yeah
I mean there's the the traditional JRPG
going into like a dungeon sort of area
and doing a turn-based battle and then
there's
slice of life a little more anime like
you're a high school student and after
school you get to kind of choose your
activities and that's been expanded a
lot and persona 5 there's more stuff you
can do so yeah there's like two two
sides to it and you can you know get to
know you were compete rias I don't know
why that was the only word I could sing
confidence second but they call them
confidants in the game there are cool
high school friends
and so I like that kind of balance I I
think I said this last week but I love
slice-of-life and I just love having
kind of that not respite because I don't
think the rest of it is like a chore or
anything but just having a step back to
breathe a little bit and explore Tokyo
and get into the world a little bit more
in between you know what you're
converting people's hearts you're fixing
bullies and stuff yeah yeah like again
to clarify Lucy James who reviewed it
for us she had loved the series and
she's knowledgeable about the series she
knows what persona 5 does differently
for more in depth look at that please
read the review watch the review I don't
have that same history so I wanted to
approach it with you guys kind of asking
me questions about my first experience
of the series and the one thing I liked
about it when you mention those
slice-of-life that social aspect I
didn't really enjoy high school in real
life so why would I care about doing
laundry and you know being this
problematic teenager and going to high
school in Tokyo because anime high
school is where it's at with this candid
completely I didn't know how dark it
would get it looked like right off the
bat right away dreamily dark yeah I
didn't know that I see what John Liu can
mention John Luke knows personally he's
like yeah people see this it's very
stylish game and like acid jazz
soundtrack and when you get in the
bowels kind of hard rock very colorful
and like you can see now like the the UI
in the HUD and the menus are all like
super stylized in this I've never never
feel away that superficial layer and you
find a game that touches on things that
most games like don't yes
like really deeply in connection suicide
and some stuff like that and I you'd
mention those flight fly things and I
was like I wish I want to play this game
but I don't care about that stuff but I
actually think because
stuff can be a grind but in the sense
that you're spending all the time right
so it almost reminded me and this is a
dumb comparison but this is my first
thing off the bat I was explaining this
to someone in our office who really
likes grand theft auto like a lot of
people when you are doing a - grand
theft auto you go around preparing for
it right and as thieves in the Metaverse
kind of like the matrix world in persona
you are going into palaces these
manifestations psychological
manifestations of people's inner desires
and personalities and you are trying to
find their treasure which will is
essentially their their core yes of
their desires which like I said in this
game some people desires that they act
on are kind of messed up and so you're
kind of exposing these bad people in the
real world by going into their
psychological Metaverse and as thieves
you're preparing for these soap-like
Heights so to speak and that's where the
high school stuff actually interested me
because I was you have a time limit
right you have like two weeks and I was
saying okay do I want to go work my
part-time job and get 2800 again so I
can buy a new weapon tomorrow or save up
for a new armor later on or do I want to
go increase my proficiency by going to
the batting cages or to the gym yeah so
then what later on when I have the
chance to use that that social stat will
help me in the Metaverse like time
management is such a big part of that
like being able to maximize your time
for what you want to do is so important
and a lot of I mean that's something I
really love and it sounds I don't know
it almost sounds like too nerdy but I'm
just like I want to make sure I do
everything perfectly that I almost get
like I have to take a break and really
think about yeah and so it's like even
more time consuming than the 100 hours
it took everybody to beat the game for
review yeah I think they're saying
average is like 105 yes um and that
seems like a lot but I wanna keep
playing it for other reasons but I do
like that there is a time limit before
you have to go into the palaces or else
you just get game over mm-hmm I mean
you're doing bored stuff you're getting
to know these characters which I want to
get into as well but I think that the
fact there is a time limit on these
things that I would otherwise consider
grinding makes them a little more
intense knowing that you're about to go
to this person's palace or that dude
combo cheetah yeah I don't spoil
anything but these are all memorable
people already and I've only played
eight hours as game I think that the
characters are also very engaging but at
first I was like oh these just seemed
like JRPG tropes they seemed like RPG
tropes in general and then they start
subverting that actually with you have
like the punk like rebel on Ryu G and
then you have the main characters kind
of the reticent sarcastic one I named
mine shooter McGavin and then you have
on lady on who right now and then you
have a Morgana the cat and it's pretty
cool yeah everybody has guns right here
now what is going on but apparently in
the real world those are model guns but
because you're in the Metaverse people
see them they think they're real and
they manifest as real guns in the
metaphors and it kind of gets into some
cool like matrix alternate reality stuff
where obviously people who know the
series know that your persona will kind
of flourish in the Metaverse Pete you're
saying so I'm a lot of times it's like
the suppressed part of people's
real-world personality that comes out
yes yeah yeah at least at the beginning
yeah that's sort of like like your stand
and like jojo's bizarre adventure it's
like the actual oh sorry no no I would
say the actual storyline is about a lot
these characters and because it's high
school I actually think that setting
fits because there are rumors floating
around and everybody has these surface
level assumptions about people and I
kind of fell into that trap I saw on and
I had these assumptions or at least
people had these rumors you kind of over
here these incidental conversations and
then people have heard these rumors
about your character and people hear
these things about Ryoji and how he's a
thug and a like a rebel and then I found
out stuff that about Rio Gees home life
and I found out something about on that
actually plays a big part of her
character how people take her beauty and
just don't look past it and then in the
Metaverse her like sexuality actually
her persona is very sexual person it's
like almost kind of sounds like a
dominatrix and it's like I think the
real world she suppresses that stuff
because she feels like she has to and
that
when it gets interesting it takes these
character archetypes and actually starts
taking what my expectations were them
based on these rumors and these things
that they were saying but then I got to
know them through that slice of life
stuff holy [ __ ] this is actually really
cool to see how that manifests and
changes in the Metaverse yeah I'm gonna
say I mean she's one of the most
relatable characters for me so far I'm
not very far in because of that and I
really exciting for Sona in general and
especially persona 5 does a great job of
making you want to do the mundane things
because it enriches everything getting
to know the characters and like
developing characters are such a strong
suit I think that the main like having
to go in and see somebody's core like
what's at the core of them is is so cool
and like such a good way to do that that
it like I mean you because you were
saying you didn't you weren't thinking
you would like to slice-of-life stuff
but I think it does a good job of making
people who aren't into that more into it
I mean like I was already like so stoked
to I'm like I'm going to go to anime
high school can't wait I'm gonna take a
test oh yeah
but I just think it's so so
intelligently done yeah I mean it was I
really actually liked that I kind of
started appreciating that so so so a lot
of its quantified obviously you get like
a rank for that person's persona so the
more the closer you get to them the more
you learn about them it'll go up and
you'll learn new skills through that
that you can use in combat which we can
talk about the combat but again the
writing was enough to it's like
melodramatic in a lot of parts but it is
very anime it's a meaner anime cutscenes
at certain bars beautiful yeah they're
really good beautifully animated I mean
there are already and I knew they would
be because there are persona animator
already yeah I just I was so delighted
opens with I mean I like that you're
kind of thrust into this immediate like
footrace opening um and starts it like
the game starts immediately and then
there's just like beautiful anime lights
and scenery is oh I love it yeah I don't
know the series but apparently persona 4
took a while to get into like it was
very slow at the beginning yeah I've
just kind of throws you right into it
but it's kind of a read it dialed it
back yeah yeah I mean a second but yeah
for the slow burn is what or the slow
start I just
into but this name definitely it
invigorates you and makes me very
curious what's happening even both of
the conflict presents on the spectacle
at the same time yeah they're good at
the start how do you guys feel about the
voiceovers because I find them to be a
little bit grating ah there is a patch
for Japanese voices like outs I cannot I
don't like playing JRPGs with English
voiceover but especially if the if the
setting is soup what I don't know I
thumbs up that because I agree with
especially if the setting is if we're in
Tokyo and we're in a clearly Japanese
high school environment everybody's
names are Japanese they pronounce
Sakamoto as a combat oh yeah super
annoying I've noticed that
gotcha um and yes I'm excited to be able
to switch to Japanese vo it's not like
hurting the experience for me but it is
like it reuses voice is really kind of
rough yeah I thought so you remind me of
like an old Ninja Turtles cartoon so the
how does a lot with anime dubs of
thuggish fresh blood archetype there's
actually another anime where the thug
character's name is Ryu G but I'm
thinking of it where the dub Boyce's are
just like they try to lean too hard into
the anime archetype and so it just comes
off as so grating and I just I think
it's like something that gets lost in
translation literally where it's like oh
like you'd like for example when a flock
of n gets translated into like southern
dialect in English it's like that's not
quite right right that's the sentiment
is there but the execution doesn't make
sense yeah it's like okay we get that
osaka supposed to be like backwoods like
in theory but the southern accent
doesn't work and so it's very similar in
english is that what the main character
posed to be from no no that's just an
example of that in dubbed
anything that's been translated from
Japanese to English yeah um when you're
trying to translate something like yok
is a dialect it when you try to sound
like a New York gangster that's just not
right well and there's a quality that
associated with the aquas I was like the
rolling of the arse and all of that is
like
Oinky like yeah like yeah why why change
it
you know we preserve it even if the
language is different because I think
there's some sentiment behind that stuff
yeah you need yeah absolutely we have a
crazy amount of time left but I do want
to get into the dungeon Carling combat
what is it so how far are you into it
I'm not very far honestly I played like
four different games yesterday I'm
juggling okay I've done the first palace
like dungeon crawl I've gotten the first
treasure the treasures are the core of
their desire personalities relevance
really quickly it is notable that
previous persona games were procedurally
generated dungeons yeah and this only
has one area that's procedurally
generated most for grinding yeah for
grant like grinding area it's like
mementos I think yeah this is they're
all like hand crafted expressions yeah
and I do like it they the combat they do
a cool I didn't realize how hard this
can get if you don't let if you don't
prepare for the palace the crawls you if
you don't have enough items especially
I've been a for like action points I've
been low on so I've been using melee hey
guys just limited ammo we got a wrap we
don't have a ton of time left like I
said but I think combats great I love
fusing persona for the main character
you can actually create new persona
you'd have to kill old parts of your
persona to choose them with new ones to
make you know like different you know
kind of classes of persona and get
different abilities everything just a
wrap I guess probably my favorite thing
is the negotiation the stuff the yeah
yeah and you get to like play with
demons and like sort of figure out like
how you can take advantage of them but
they often turn the tables and take
advantage of you because they think yeah
because you think that you know
everything yeah you can say give me an
item it's a holdup if you start
everybody in the party using elemental
weaknesses or getting critical hits or
using weapons when they're weak to them
everybody a party like goes and points a
gun to them and give me an item give me
money or lend me your power if you don't
have that persona yet and they'll say I
have to see if it would be a good fit or
something like that and the higher level
ones will ask more riddles than actual
yeah flat-out show you their personality
so this one guy I can tell he just
mischievous so I just did and you have
like three response choices and if you
get if you make a bond with them right
there then you can get their persona and
down the road fuse it with another one
to make it stronger and I really like
those or you can just do it all out it's
happen everybody
yeah [ __ ] destroyed them yeah like I
said you can go watch more in depth
video review and read the review by Lucy
James her and two more put a lot of time
in the game Miguel concepción here
played a lot of it and he's been doing a
lot of guide stuffs and capturing for us
and he's going we're going to have more
persona 5 coverage on gamespot con so
stay tuned for that and go play his game
it's fun
[Music]